[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMY STARR: Jim is the author
of the award-winning cocktail
book, "The PDT Cocktail Book,"
as well as his newer release,
"Meehan's Bartender Manual."
In an article from
"Imbibe" magazine,
they described it as ambitious.
And actually, in
that same article,
you went in and mentioned it
was his midlife crisis project.
But the word that comes to mind
when I first began reading it
was thorough.
It really does cover the
breadth of every aspect
of the business, when
we're talking about recipes
and techniques, the
history of cocktail making,
as well as service
and hospitality.
But more importantly, the thing
about having a Chicago native
here to talk about this, even
though his career has taken him
all over the country, is what
we're known for in Chicago--
being neighborly, we know
our local watering holes,
and we know a lot about our
rich, historic architecture.
So with his newer project,
your neighbor, Prairie School,
we are talking about
the influence that
comes from Frank Lloyd
Wright's Prairie School
aesthetic and the Japanese
cultural influence
that that has, as well as being
neighbors to a great cocktail
bar.
So with that,
welcome Jim Meehan.
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, Amy.
AMY STARR: Congratulations
on the book.
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you.
AMY STARR: Like I
said, it's great.
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you so much.
AMY STARR: I read it all.
JIM MEEHAN: This one
has a lot of words in it
compared to the last one--
AMY STARR: Lots of words.
JIM MEEHAN: --which
was basically--
AMY STARR: Still
plenty of pictures.
JIM MEEHAN: --like a
children's book with recipes.
Yeah.
AMY STARR: Plenty of pictures.
Still great illustrations.
And not only thorough,
very thoughtful as well.
How do you think
that this book can
translate to your
readers that are not
hospitality professionals?
JIM MEEHAN: I think that
when I wrote this book,
I sort of had "Zen and the
Art of Motorcycle Maintenance"
in the back of my mind.
I started bartending in
Madison, Wisconsin, in 1995.
I've always loved parties, but
I realized later in my life
that I'm an introvert.
And I like the idea of parties
more than I like partying.
And I found that working in bars
allowed me to be at the party
but not necessarily be
in the mosh pit there.
And so I guess after
20-plus years of this--
bartending, making
cocktails, serving people--
I've kind of begun to
start extrapolating how
this is sort of a way of life.
You hear the maxim that everyone
should work in a restaurant
or work as a server
or a bartender
at some point in their life.
And as I have gotten
older and started
thinking about
what I do, and when
I started writing
this book, I realized
that I came into
bartending through books.
So in 1995, as all of
you are aware at Google,
the internet wasn't
the capital I internet.
We didn't learn how
to do all the things
that we know how to do through
YouTube or through googling it.
And if you wanted
to know something,
you had to go to a library or
find someone who could get you
the book.
So I learned about the
history of bartending,
the history of cocktails,
even in some ways,
once I was able to find
some of the older books,
about bartending through books.
And one of the things
I've found that kind
of runs through all of the
books is, a lot of books
tell you the who, what,
when, where, and how,
but a lot of books
don't tell you why.
And I would say for me,
as I've gotten older
and kind of been doing
this longer and longer,
I've found that, as a young
bartender, as a young manager,
I always thought that
the way to get everyone
to get on the same page with
me was to lead by example.
And I came to a certain
point in my career
where I realized that by
setting a very high example,
by striving towards
perfection, it actually
was incredibly discouraging
to a lot of the people who
work with me.
And in some ways, the way
in which I carried myself
didn't motivate them to
want to work with me.
It made them sort of shirk away
from wanting to work with me.
And I found in writing this
book and then, eventually,
transitioning in
management style,
that if I actually showed
people why I did things the way
that I did them, they
could think about them
and come to their own
sense of why they think
that is a good way
or, more importantly,
we can open a dialogue up
about what the best way would
be to all do it together.
And so when I wrote
this book, I was
thinking about not just
the who, what, when, where,
and how, but the why.
And I think in the same
way as within your life
and your business and
my life and my business,
I feel like that process of
understanding that there are
many paths to a destination
is something that
is important to understand.
There are many
ways to do things.
And what I said right from the
very beginning in this book is,
there are many ways to do
this job, and here is mine.
And I think the more in which
either bartenders or architects
or chefs or software
designers can
talk about their
process and the process
which they use to get
to their destination--
but that actual
process, once you've
formed it and come to certain
ideas or conclusions about it,
can be very useful
to many people.
AMY STARR: Excellent.
So I mentioned, of course, the
influence of Frank Lloyd Wright
in opening Prairie School.
How did that project come about?
How did your partnership
with Heisler Hospitality
come around?
And tell us more about
the influence in the space
and your cocktail program?
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah.
So when I listen to a lot
of successful people talk
about their career
or their life,
this sort of idea of manifest
destiny usually creeps into it.
And you hear of a story of the
self-made person who always
wanted to do X, and
their whole life
has been this series of
just moving towards X.
And I think for
me and my career,
I wish it was like that.
I always wanted to be a doctor.
But that didn't work.
So my life has not been a
story of manifest destiny.
My life has been a story
of opportunism and sort
of understanding
what I was good at
and what I enjoyed
doing, and trying
to keep doing more of what I
was good at and enjoyed doing.
While Oak Park and River
Forest are wealthy places,
my dad was worked at
Maywood race track
in the emission department.
My mom was a schoolteacher
at St. Giles teaching art,
first, and then third grade.
And we didn't have a
lot of family money.
So most of what
I've done in life
came from amazing opportunities
being foisted upon me.
Like, do you want to
edit "Food and Wine"
magazine's cocktail book?
Yes.
Are you qualified?
You know, just fake
it 'til you make it.
AMY STARR: Exactly.
JIM MEEHAN: Yes, I'm qualified.
I've been saying I've been
qualified to do things
since I was very young.
And so I guess the exciting
part about Prairie School--
like PDT, for instance,
people think that I just
opened my bar in
New York on my own,
whereas I was actually brought
into PDT as a consulting
opportunity through
one of the regulars I
had at the first
restaurant I worked in.
And they were two guys.
One of them owned
a hot dog stand.
The other was his kind
of childhood best friend.
And they had kind of designed
this kind of crazy bar,
and they just didn't know
how to serve cocktails.
So they brought me in to show
them how to serve cocktails.
And then we kind of have
been involved ever since.
AMY STARR: So the phone
booth was the chicken
and the cocktails were the egg.
JIM MEEHAN: The phone booth--
AMY STARR: Vice versa?
JIM MEEHAN: --the taxidermy,
all the sort of fun parts
are Brian Shebairo, my partner.
And all the parts that I'm
passionate about-- the service,
the drinks, the environment--
are me, which no one really
cares about or copies.
But with respect
to Prairie School,
it was amazingly serendipitous.
I was at my favorite bar,
probably in the world,
Bar Radio in Tokyo.
And it's this tiny little
beautiful, perfect, tiny space.
And I was enjoying
cocktails at the bar.
And there's never any
Americans in there.
And there was someone in
there speaking English.
And I didn't go there
to talk to Americans.
But towards the end of
our visit, he said hello,
and very humbly said that he
was a bar owner in Chicago,
and we exchanged cards.
And we met later
again in Berlin.
And then we would kind of talk.
And eventually, we
did meet in Chicago.
And his partner Matt
Eisler, they both
opened Sportsman's
together, and I always
love the Sportsman's Club.
And I stayed in touch
with them for a few years.
And then finally, Matt
and I had a conversation
about working together.
And then last winter, I guess
it was, Matt drove me down
to this neighborhood when
that was a construction site
and said, there's a
potential opportunity
to open something here.
What do you think?
And I was like, yes, I'd like
to open a bar in the Google
building across from the
new Ace hotel in the hottest
neighborhood in Chicago.
That sounds great.
OK.
And the thing that's
most, I think,
exciting for me
is that I grew up
kitty-cornered to a Frank Lloyd
Wright house in River Forest
and drove past the sort
of temple every day
to high school.
And I feel like this project
allows me to explore my roots.
I left Chicago or
the Chicagoland area.
People who grew
up in Chicago get
very upset when you
say you're from Chicago
when you aren't
from the 312 area.
But I left this area
when I was 18 years old
and never came back.
I tended bar every summer.
And then I went to New York.
And so it's amazing
to come home and to be
able to learn about
Chicago and how
it came to be through this bar.
And I feel like,
in opening bars,
when you're able to put a
little bit of yourself--
a little bit of your
history and your story--
in the bar that you
have sort of operated,
it's something that, I
think, really draws people
in and sort of resonates.
I think with respect to
the cocktails themselves,
a cocktail, other than being
delicious and intoxicating,
ideally, is something
that tells a story.
And I think a bar in and of
itself should tell a story.
So Prairie School kind of
does that for me personally.
For us, as Chicagoans, it
allows us to celebrate something
that I think maybe
flies under the radar,
not necessarily for
Chicagoans, but for people
around the world.
They don't understand
that Chicago really
is a design and architecture
mecca, globally.
AMY STARR: And it does
a really great job
of walking the line, too,
between inspiration and kitsch
being too much of a theme.
Y'all came to the
right talk today,
because we have taster sizes for
you of the Tall Boxes cocktail
that they offer
at Prairie School.
You want to tell us
more about Tall Boxes?
JIM MEEHAN: Well, first, I'll
point out the team over here.
That's Mony and Christina--
[APPLAUSE]
--the real bartenders.
There was there was
talk of a cocktail demo,
and I said, no,
no, no, let's let
the real bartenders handle it.
So thank you guys.
So I learned how to tend bar, as
I said, in Madison, Wisconsin.
And back in the
late 20th century
the brandy Old
Fashioned was a thing.
That was what people
drank in Wisconsin.
They still do.
And it wasn't the modern--
actually, the old Old
Fashioned, that sort of
has become popular--
just bitters, sugar,
booze, and a twist.
That was actually something
that we didn't make back then.
What we made right
back then would
be called the Old Fashioned
with the garbage in it.
And the garbage meant that you
muddled in orange and cherry
and sugar with the bitters,
and then you added the brandy,
and then you'd probably
shook it and maybe you
poured it-- you did any number
of things with it back then.
AMY STARR: A Brussels sprout.
JIM MEEHAN: Any number of
mixological atrocities--
yeah, a Brussels
sprout, a mushroom,
poured Sprite on top of it.
But when I was looking at
writing the original menu
for this bar, I
wanted to make sure
that we were
celebrating the Midwest
and celebrating
things legitimately.
And so our house Old Fashioned,
we call the Tall Boxes.
It's this drink.
It's bitters and one muddled
cherry and one Kirsch brandied
Morello cherry.
We press that.
We don't mash it
into the garbage.
And then we add
Sacred Bond brandy,
which is not like
the Korbel we used
to pour back in Wisconsin, which
is probably mostly corn syrup.
And we stir it, and
then we fine strain it.
So it actually looks like
the sort of more elegant,
old school Old Fashioned.
But it actually was made
the Wisconsin-style way.
And if you come
downstairs and have it--
and I highly encourage of all
of you to come down to Prairie
School and have it--
the glass is obviously a sort
of cylindrical double Old
Fashioned glass.
It comes with a big clear cube
that is stenciled with our sort
of Frank Lloyd Wright-inspired--
Actually, this is our
logo at Prairie School.
Taking the architectural details
off the top of the building
is what you'll see here, and
stretching them out and kind of
bringing them down to the base.
And then we use Frank Lloyd
Wright's signature red box,
which he put in his blueprints
as his sort of sign-off.
So we stencil that into the ice.
And then what you'll see
with this garnished is,
the cherry is a
sphere, and we've
cut the orange into a triangle.
So if you see it
in the glass, it's
a cube, a sphere, a
triangle in a cylinder.
And the idea is
really sort of looking
at how Frank Lloyd Wright
architecture sort of used a lot
of those different elements.
So it's a really simple drink.
It's a drink that all
Midwesterners who have ventured
to Wisconsin are familiar with.
But we've sort of
refined it and made
it more simple and
elemental, which
is something I think that
Frank Lloyd Wright did.
AMY STARR: All right.
One of my favorite lines
or quotes from your book
is that you refer to
bartenders as both craftspeople
and salespeople.
It's evident in how
your career has evolved.
But now that you've stepped
out from behind the bar--
you've already alluded a little
bit to how you've progressed,
but can you tell us
more in particular
as to what opportunities
made you decide to take
a side-step toward consulting?
And how do you choose
the next project?
Where do you find the
inspiration or influence there?
JIM MEEHAN: Well, as
I sort of mentioned,
I wish the manifest
destiny element came in
and I just chose my projects.
But really, I don't
choose the projects.
The projects sort of choose me.
And I feel like, in some ways,
my life has been a series of--
it's like when one door
closes, another door opens up.
I feel like for me, personally,
a lot of the way opportunity
comes my way is by making
myself open to opportunity,
and by always considering
opportunities.
I would say that for
those of you who have ever
worked in bars or
who know bartenders,
bartenders are probably one of
the most opportunistic bunch
of people you've probably ever--
AMY STARR: I was ready for
you to say masochistic.
JIM MEEHAN: No, I
say opportunistic.
I mean, a bartender
is always keenly
interested in whatever sort
of scheme you have in mind--
something worth considering.
So I would say that I wish
I could call my shots.
But that isn't
necessarily how it works.
But I will say that the
projects that I'm always
open to consider and the sort of
thought process I go through--
when I realized
that I wasn't going
to become a doctor because
organic chemistry and calculus
were going to prevent
me from getting an A--
a five and seven-credit A--
I just was like, it's
not going to happen.
And I looked through
the syllabus,
and I picked up an
honors French class.
And I called a professor who
was teaching a graduate level
seminar on the
Harlem Renaissance.
And I was like, will you
let me in your class?
I've never taken any of these
African-American Studies
classes, but this sounds
really interesting.
And she let me in.
And it was the
first class I took
at Wisconsin that didn't have,
like, 600 people in my class.
It was, like, 30 people--
no, like, maybe 20 people.
And I remember raising
my hand one day
and asking who
W.E.B. Du Bois was.
And everyone turned
around and was like--
[MAKES INQUISITIVE NOISE]
But I ended up double
majoring after taking
three of Sandra Adell's classes
in African-American Studies.
So I always tell
people, depending
on the crowd and the
television camera,
that I majored in books
and black people, which
is why I became a bartender.
But for me, my
career has largely
been based off of growing up,
listening to early rap music,
and seeing how this
rap music turned
into this hip-hop
culture, and how
certain artists
within that culture
were able to identify
elements of rap music
that could be extrapolated
into fashion or into liquid
or into design or into
many different disciplines.
And I feel like with
cocktails, there
is a culture to cocktails.
There's a sort of sensibility
that manifests itself.
And I feel like a
lot of the projects
I choose, whether it be
designing my own bar bag,
or working on a spice line
with a friend who mostly works
with chefs, or collaborating
with American Express
to do cocktails in
airports, where it's usually
impossible to get
a good cocktail,
these are opportunities for
me to bring cocktail culture
or bring elements of our
culture to a place where
maybe people didn't
realize they wanted it
and they would want it.
And it allows me to
work with people who
have skills that I don't have.
I really enjoy meeting Googlers.
I remember at the last
Google talk I did,
Nick Anderer, who was the
chef at Gramercy Tavern
and now is the chef at Maialino,
his brother is a brain surgeon
and introduced me to Googler,
who, after his Google talk,
emailed me.
And he actually went and
used my app and he created--
you guys, I'm sure, know
what this is called.
But it was, like, a data map
that was in three dimensions.
And so there were certain
nodes where an ingredient was,
and every drink that
used that ingredient
had all of these lines in it.
And it was this crazy
three-dimensional map,
so you could kind of see which
ingredients you use the most.
It was like a cloud.
And it was brilliant.
So I feel like for
me, the projects
that I gravitate towards are
the ones that take me out
of my Dungeons and Dragons-esque
culture into, ideally, a more
broad universe where I can speak
to people of other disciplines
and figure out where we can
sort of find common ground.
AMY STARR: Yeah.
And more to learn, always.
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah.
AMY STARR: Kind of a
Choose Your Own Adventure.
JIM MEEHAN: But not choosing.
AMY STARR: Finding the
dark alley to go down next.
With that being said,
then, any red flags?
Do you have a standard
set of red flags
being like, definitely not
going down that dark alley?
That dark alley's a no.
JIM MEEHAN: I am a red flag.
AMY STARR: I'll choose
this less dim one.
JIM MEEHAN: One
of my colleagues,
who was employing me-- so
I guess he was my boss--
he once called me
his "insult-ant,"
not his consultant.
And I find that the
red flags are really,
in all of my
projects, do you have
an affinity for being honest,
being open, being transparent?
I find that a lot of people
you meet in the world,
especially people who have a lot
of power, unfortunately, really
just want you to
affirm what they think.
They're looking for
people to validate them.
AMY STARR: Yes, they are.
JIM MEEHAN: And I don't think
about the title of the person
that I'm talking to
or how rich they are
or what school they went to
or how much they can bench
press before I tell
them what I think.
And the people who have
a problem with that
generally don't enjoy
working with me.
So I'm, fortunately
or unfortunately,
my own best red flag.
AMY STARR: In terms
of new projects,
and once you've kind of
found that new route,
do generally find inspiration
like you find an opportunity,
or do you have any traditions
or methodologies to help you
get past a creative roadblock?
JIM MEEHAN: I don't have
creative roadblocks, which
sounds--
AMY STARR: Lucky you.
JIM MEEHAN: --really
sort of pretentious.
But I feel like for me, the
way in which I work creatively,
a lot of is just
based on history.
And I would say that with
respect to cocktails,
I'm not a fashion designer,
but I would imagine
creating cocktails or
even cocktail programs is
a lot like either creating
a piece of clothing
or creating a line of clothing.
And a lot of it really
is reflective of history.
And I would say that
for any of you who
have been into cocktails
for any period of time,
it's amazing how
what's old becomes new
and what was just
recently popular
kind of goes out of style, even
though it was a good thing.
And you'll find at
times, also, that things
are starting to creep back in
that shouldn't be creeping back
in.
But they're coming back because
of the way the pendulum swings.
And I find that for me,
personally, by studying history
as a designer or as
a sort of creative,
I understand where things are
going because I understand
where they've been.
And I don't look
at only cocktails.
I look at general zeitgeist.
Creativity is something, I
would say, that, for me--
especially having lived in
New York, I would say that--
and this would probably make
some creative people unhappy--
but it's like, in some ways,
being creative or being
innovative is really a matter--
at Google, this must feel
good, because it is probably
what you do and are.
But in so many
ways, being creative
is about connecting
the dots, and it's
about taking data and putting
it together and packaging it
in such a way, and
then really kind
of racing to get it out
first and to get it out
in such a way that
resonates with an audience.
I know you wanted to ask
me about naming cocktails.
But it's so interesting--
to preempt the question--
AMY STARR: Tell us
about naming cocktails.
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah.
So I mean, I would say
that with naming cocktails,
some designers or
creatives would say there's
nothing new under the sun.
But with cocktails,
a lot of it really
revolves around putting
together the ingredients
or putting together
the different elements
of a cocktail.
That's, like, half
of the battle.
The other half the battle
is naming the drink
and giving those
elements a name.
I would say that the
name of a cocktail
is really, in many ways, its
business plan or its marketing
plan.
And with respect to the first
drink you had, the Tall Boxes,
you know, what do
you call a brandy
Old Fashioned that
you've sort of not
really done that much to except
maybe "Frank Lloyd Wright-ify"
it?
Well, you have to think
of, all right, well
what is going to be catchy?
When I think of a cocktail
name, I think about,
is this something that people
can pronounce in English
and Spanish and Korean?
Is it something
that's easy to spell?
A lot of times young
bartenders will
create a drink with
tequila and come up
with a Spanish name for it.
And you're just like, come on.
So with respect to the Tall
Boxes, the origin of that name
was that Frank Lloyd
Wright, 100 years ago,
was describing skyscrapers with
what he called "tall boxes."
And he was saying
it with some scorn.
And it's interesting,
with that first drink,
most people would think of
the brandy Old Fashioned
with the garbage in
it with some scorn.
So Frank Lloyd Wright
actually ended up
designing some skyscrapers.
None of them really
got built. But the idea
was bringing in the
concept of Prairie School
and bringing Frank
Lloyd Wright in,
in a sort of tangential
way to this drink
that kind of ties in everything.
And in many ways, to me,
a great cocktail title
ties in as many different
elements as possible.
And so it signifies, on
a very elemental level.
But that signification
can go down low.
One of the things I've realized,
as I speak about my trade,
is that information
is like an iceberg.
Present too much information
to people, like an iceberg,
if we were all in our canoe
as the polar ice caps melt
and icebergs won't
exist anymore--
but imagine the polar ice caps
still had icebergs in them,
and we were in a boat, and
you saw a giant iceberg.
What you would do is, you
would probably sail around it
so your ship didn't
crash into the iceberg.
Information is like that.
Show too much ice, the
person goes way around it.
I don't to know
this much about it.
Show too little
ice, and then you
crash your boat up right
against it and you capsize.
So I find that a drink like
the Tall Boxes, you could just
not really understand why
it's called the Tall Boxes,
order it, drink it.
Fine.
But there's a lot
more underneath it.
And then the same
thing kind of goes
for this next drink we
have, the King Kamehameha.
Fortunately, our
director of operations
grew up in Hawaii, so he was
able to correctly show me
how to say Kamehameha.
AMY STARR: I googled it.
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah.
You could Google it.
But you have to use the,
like, pronounce-it app.
But this is just a
traditional punch.
So this is a
Taiwanese tea that's
really sort of rich
and sweet and kind
of tobacco-y with a pot-stilled
rum with lemon juice,
maple syrup, and just nutmeg.
And I chose to name it
the King Kamehameha.
I was sort of stretching
here, but Frank Lloyd Wright c
structures all over the world.
And one of his
structures was recently
rebuilt by Taliesin
Architects in Hawaii.
So obviously, a drink that
has sort of a rum punch
would make sense to have a sort
of Frank Lloyd Wright-y sort
of tropical element.
Not all of our
drinks, by the way,
are named after
Frank Lloyd Wright.
AMY STARR: OK.
Let's talk more about
how technology ties in.
You discuss, in your history
section of the manual--
but also, as you
briefly said earlier,
you spent a lot of time
with cocktail books.
And it wasn't always so easy
to find these original editions
and everything else.
Now that we have
the internet readily
at our fingertips at all times--
we have Google here--
and as Googlers, and as a
verb that we use most often,
how else has technology been
integrated into the hospitality
world?
And how do you think we can
be more careful and thoughtful
in how we use it?
JIM MEEHAN: This is
a great question.
I was sort of like,
ooh, this is tough.
So if you look at
modern cocktail history,
one of my favorite books was
"Vintage Spirits and Forgotten
Cocktails" by Ted Haigh.
And Ted Haigh was the
original moderator on one
of AOL'S chat groups.
And if you look at where this
modern cocktail renaissance
came back, the second
edition of his book
actually has an
additional chapter
that was 25 of the most
influential cocktail
bloggers of all times.
And I remember when I bought
this book, as a guy who
thinks he's an important
modern bartender,
I looked at the
back of this book,
and I was like, why is this guy
giving credit to 25 bloggers
instead of actually
giving credit to--
because it came out many years
later-- to the bartenders
who actually brought
the drinks back?
And many years later, as I've
sat here and shrunk my head
and become less
of an egomaniac, I
realized that if you
read that chapter,
you'll see how important
DrinkBoy and all
of the early cocktail--
how, basically, this
renaissance was incubated
in internet chat rooms.
And I don't have a cogent,
long argument to make here,
and I won't make it to you guys.
But I would argue that the
reason why the cocktail
renaissance kind of came back
had a lot to do with technology
and had a lot to do
with technologists being
really interested in cocktails.
The two guys that
I opened PDT with,
Don Lee, who
created our Benton's
Old Fashioned, and John
[INAUDIBLE],, who's a CTO.
He goes from one company to the
next and gets another buyout,
and just keeps getting
richer and richer.
But it's two tech guys.
And I find that it's amazing--
whenever I meet programmers,
they're always into cocktails,
and always know way
more about it than I do.
So I would say that the whole
modern cocktail renaissance
kind of came about with the rise
of the internet and information
technology.
But in many ways, Prairie School
is a response to something
which I haven't liked
over the last, probably,
five, six, seven, eight years,
which is, what I've found
is that as so many
bartenders learn
how to bartend on
YouTube from watching
YouTube videos of their
favorite bartenders
in London or in Japan or in
Singapore or in Barcelona, what
I've found is, there's been
a homogenization of cocktail
styles.
When I finally got
the chance to travel,
probably starting
around 2003 or 2004
to visit distilleries
and other bars
and bartenders all over the
world, it was very cool to me
how this sort of throwing
techniques, which you'll
see progressive,
trying-too-hard bars
nowadays probably
here in Chicago,
that came from Morocco.
And then really, you would
only see that in Barcelona.
And then the Japanese
hard shake, obviously,
came from Tokyo, and was
brought all over the world
by a bartender from Bratislava
in Stanislav Vardrna.
But to make a long
story short, now,
when you go to a
bar in Indianapolis,
you'll see the Japanese
hard shake technique,
you'll see the
[INAUDIBLE] long throw,
you'll see Australian chat.
And you'll just see this sort
of monster hybrid homogenization
of this perfect cocktail
competition-winning bartender
that, to me, has lost
its "Indianapolis-ness."
And I find that when I go to
a great bar in Indianapolis,
it has the same bottles
on the back bar,
the same Japanese cocktail
shakers as in Tokyo.
It's like the same
bar everywhere.
The bars in Berlin are like
the bars in Indianapolis
are like the bars in Auckland
are like the bars in Moscow.
And I've found
that, in some ways,
it takes the joy
out of going to bars
and finding the weird
idiosyncratic tics that
make certain people
the way they are.
I've found that culture is
incubated and sort of preserved
quite beautifully in its
culinary and drinking
traditions.
And I find, in some ways,
that YouTube mostly, but also
the internet, has sort
of made us more global.
And I think that's
certainly a great thing.
But the challenge is--
and it's a question I would ask
you guys-- how do we figure out
ways to better preserve
our unique cultural sort
of weirdness, like our
brandy Old Fashioned?
I think Malort's terrible.
But how do you
make sure that you
know that Malort is something
that these weird Chicago
people like drinking, even
though it's not delicious?
AMY STARR: Without
homogenizing everything.
JIM MEEHAN: Right.
AMY STARR: Yeah.
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah.
Like, I don't want to drink
Jeppson's Malort in Berlin,
even though you like
Chicago in Berlin.
AMY STARR: Hey, Chicago!
Drink Malort!
JIM MEEHAN: Actually,
I think Malort--
well, whatever.
I'll leave Malort
alone for a minute.
AMY STARR: All right.
We want to prepare for some Q&A.
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah.
We got five more minutes.
AMY STARR: We got
some questions here.
I hope you all have some
questions to ask for Jim.
Volunteers here will
bring the mic to you.
Miss?
And just wait until we
have the mic in your hand.
AUDIENCE: So a question
about naming the cocktails--
how often do people ask
you about the names?
And are you kind of secretly
hoping that they do?
JIM MEEHAN: I am really
hoping that people
ask lots of questions.
Yes.
So I mean, I wish people
asked lots of questions.
Part of what I would
consider great bartending,
going back to that iceberg
theory of information,
is really gathering
a sense of why
someone has come to your bar.
And I mention this in
the service chapter.
A huge part of bartending
is just reading the data,
looking at the situation.
So for instance, I
think, in some ways,
just like in life, we
all want to be noticed.
We all want to be
interesting and desirable
and want people to
ask us all the things
that we are passionate about.
So yes, in my
narcissistic little heart,
I would love for you
to ask me about how
I came up with these
little children of mine.
But realistically,
when you show up
at the bar with your suitcase
or looking at your Tinder app
or with your parents--
there's a lot of reasons
why people come to a bar.
And I think a great
bartender understands
that you have to serve the guest
based on why they're there.
So yes, the answer
to the question
is, I do want you to
ask me about my drinks.
But I have to be
disciplined and I
have to understand that you
might be there for a date
or for a business meeting or
to catch up with your friends
or just to get any old drink.
And I have to give
you that experience.
And I think that,
with respect to bars,
and especially with
respect to cocktail bars,
I would describe bars,
and especially my bars,
as what I would call
elaborate traps.
And what I mean by that
is that so many times,
you'll go to a cocktail bar.
And let's just say we
go to cocktail bars,
usually, because
you hear about them.
And if Mary Doyle, your amazing
PR and marketing director,
does such a great job, you're
in the media all the time.
So people come because they
read about you somewhere.
But in the event you
don't have a Mary Doyle
or you're 10 or 11
years old like PDT
and no one writes about
you because you're
10 or 11 years
old, your business
is driven by word of mouth.
And so most of the people
who come to the bars
that I am involved with
are coming because someone
brought them there.
And the reality is, that someone
is probably a cocktail geek.
But the five people that
they bring, one of them
might be a cocktail geek.
But probably the other
three or four of them
are only there because
they like their friend.
And maybe they
hate cocktail bars.
And so a lot of times,
they'll go to a cocktail bar.
They don't even want
to go to this bar.
And then they'll
look at the menu.
They'll not see
anything on the menu
that they want because
they don't like
cocktails and cocktail bars.
And they'll order
a glass of wine.
And the bartender
or the waiter will
make them feel bad for
ordering a glass of wine.
And that will reinforce why
they don't like cocktail bars.
And then they'll
just be miserable.
And what I like to
happen in my bars
is, you get dragged by
your friend to my bar,
and you order a glass of
wine, and the server is not
mean to you, and they have
a somewhat thoughtful glass
of wine to order.
And then you get
your glass of wine,
and you realize
everyone else around you
is drinking cocktails.
And you have, like, 20 minutes
to actually take in the scene,
maybe try some of your
colleagues' drinks.
And by 20 minutes
later, the chances
that you are open to
one of these cocktails
becomes greater, and then
maybe you order a cocktail
the second time around.
And then you're mine.
So that's sort of
the way in which I
think bars should be run.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So this is kind of
a personal question.
So I'm from Cuba.
And my favorite cocktail
is a daiquiri-- like,
a classic daiquiri.
And it's incredibly
hard around the city
to get a bartender to even
know what I'm talking about.
They'll always immediately go to
the frozen daiquiri party scene
of New Orleans or something.
And I'm curious what
your take is on that--
on sort of these classic
cocktails being either
forgotten or kind of shifting
to this super popular sugary
frozen--
AMY STARR: We gotta find out
where you're hanging out first.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
even nice bars,
they will have a
hard time sometimes
making a good daiquiri.
JIM MEEHAN: The
struggle is real.
So the second drink you
had, the King Kamehameha,
is made with Banks 7 rum.
I helped create
that brand and have
been working as an international
brand ambassador of sorts
for Banks since 2009.
And this involved me making
daiquiris all over the world.
And I will say that the
daiquiri is the hardest drink
to make in the entire world.
And it's funny.
I agree with you.
When I first started introducing
the daiquiri to people,
a lot of times, you go to a bar,
and you'd asked for a daiquiri,
and they'd say,
oh, I'm so sorry,
we're out of strawberries,
or, I'm so sorry.
AMY STARR: No blender.
JIM MEEHAN: The
blender's broken,
or we don't have a blender.
And you'd be like,
well, that's OK.
Do you have rum?
Yes.
Do you have lime?
Do you have sugar?
Yes.
I'm like, we can
make a daiquiri.
But the thing I've found
is that there's nothing
simple about this drink.
The limes change
pH all the time.
A barista would
be better equipped
mentally to make a daiquiri.
Because they understand
that the coffee
bean, their main material, is
an ever-changing agricultural
product.
The lime is as well.
Their sweetness and
sourness and "limeyness"
change at all times.
The simple syrup that you
use to make the daiquiri
changes based on the aptitude
and interest and focus
of the person who makes the
simple syrup for your bar.
Or if you're so sad that
you buy sugar syrup in,
that sugar syrup is
filled with stabilizers
that makes it not so
simple and actually
quite flavorful in a
really chemical way.
And the other thing
about the daiquiri
is, it is the elemental drink of
strong rum, sweet sugar, sour.
So you would think
that that is something
that's easy to balance.
But what I've found in
my career, which I guess
could also probably relate
to everyone's life--
it was a very "Matrix"
moment in my career.
We were talking earlier about--
as a young bartender who's,
like, really serious--
maybe you have a mustache or
some tattoos or shirt garters
and arm garters or something.
Like, you take yourself
really serious.
AMY STARR: Suspenders.
JIM MEEHAN: As a young bartender
that takes your craft really
seriously, you spend all
of this time creating
the perfect recipes.
And when the guest inevitably
sends the drinks back,
the first thing you think
is, what's wrong with you?
And you get bitter, as opposed
to realizing that everyone
has a different palate.
And the truly "Matrix"
moment for me,
when the bullets came
at me much more slowly
and everything started
to make more sense
was, I realized that if I
stopped at creating drinks
with this even notion that
you could have a perfectly
balanced drink, I would have a
chance in pleasing more people.
So I guess the long way of
answering your question--
[BEEPING]
--is that-- are
we about to blow?
The long way of
answering your question
is, the reason why you probably
can't find a perfect daiquiri
is because we all have a
different conception of like,
it needs to be too strong,
too sweet, too sour.
And those variables, which
you would think are easy,
change every day.
And I would say, to
speak to your pain,
that we've gotten away from--
and this is me soapboxing,
saying, look what I'm doing
and everyone else is
not because I'm old.
We've gotten away
from elemental drinks,
like two drinks you had-- a
classic five-ingredient punch
or a classic Old Fashioned.
And we want to make the
Hemingway daiquiri before we
ever make the daiquiri.
And I think that
these simple drinks,
like the daiquiri, which is a
bike with a kickstand on it--
a three-ingredient drink or
even a two-ingredient drink,
like our highball, are
actually much more complicated,
I would argue, to
make really well
than these five-ingredient
drinks with Malort.
AUDIENCE: I also went
to school at Madison.
JIM MEEHAN: Yes!
AUDIENCE: And I was just curious
what your favorite bar there
is.
JIM MEEHAN: Oh, my gosh.
I worked at Paul's Club
for four and a half years,
and it was my favorite
bar until they moved it.
The new bar does not feel as
"Paul's Clubby" as it used to.
If I had to pick a favorite
bar in Madison right now,
as I think back--
I mean, the bars I loved
there were around the square.
So I love Jenna's.
And I've always loved
The Tornado Room.
I think that the bar around
the corner there is amazing.
So I guess I'm going to pick
a favorite bar right now,
it would be Jenna's.
AUDIENCE: Working
in New York, you
have a lot of great
partners there--
Brian Miller, Dale DeGroff,
the late Sasha Petraske.
Do you have any main influences
while you working there?
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah.
When I moved to New York, I
moved to Stanton and Clinton,
and I was very fortunate to be
there right when wd~50 opened.
So Eben Freeman was the
head bartender there.
And Shiller's
Liquor Bar actually
opened over on Norfolk and
Rivington just maybe a year
or two after that.
So I was very fortunate when I
moved there to be able to have
shift drinks with Eben at wd~50.
Dewey Dufresne, Wiley's dad,
was a really amazing wine
and spirits collector.
And I drank most of the 1900s
armagnac for free during those
days.
And Dushan Jaric and Jay Kosmas,
who opened Employees Only,
the last bar that they worked
out for Keith McNally was
at Shiller's.
So between those two bars, it
was sort of really influential
for me.
And then my first
sort of aha moment
was when Eben took me late
one night to Milk and Honey
in 2003.
I'll never forget going there.
Joseph Schwartz, who opened
Little Branch with Sasha
was working on the
floor, and Toby Maloney,
who opened the Violet
Hour here and ended up
opening The Pegu Club as
the head bartender with me,
was behind the bar.
And I had a Gold Rush cocktail.
And it was a drink that TJ
Siegel, who was Sasha's best
friend, created.
And it was a simple combination
of bourbon and lemon juice
and honey.
Both Toby and Joseph were
wearing the banker's garb.
And Joseph had this
beautiful silver tray
with a candle on it.
And he was just very elegant
and very accommodating
in the way served it.
They served this drink to me
in an ice cold Old Fashioned
glass with a hand-carved
piece of ice.
Going back to the daiquiri,
it was a perfect sour
with Eljah Craig and
lemon juice and honey.
And the environment was amazing.
One of the things that has been
sort of lost in translation
as we think about this sort
of modern cocktail renaissance
is that Milk and Honey,
really, back in those days,
was a refuge.
Before apps were the way
that people met each other,
people met each other in bars.
And bars were really sort of, in
my opinion, somewhat predatory,
knuckle-dragging
places where people
kind of just like glommed onto
each other and got wasted.
And I didn't really like that.
Milk and Honey was
like going to church.
And so that was sort of a huge
game-changing moment for me,
where I was considering
focusing on wine
and maybe being a
sommelier when I grew up.
And I realized
that, at that point,
I'd been a bartender
for eight years,
really loved it, and saw
this kind of escape route
into bartending.
And so certainly, Sasha
and Joseph and Eben
were early
inspirations, and then
obviously Audrey Saunders and
Julie Reiner and many others.
I think that when you
speak to a lot of sort
of successful people
or important people,
they want to tell you that
they were inspired or mentored
by the most famous people that
they know or ever worked with.
And I would say,
for me, I've always
made a point of trying
to learn something
from everybody I worked with.
And I would say that every
single person I've worked with
has taught me something
about my career, about myself
that I didn't know.
And I maintain
that if you remain
open to knowing
more about yourself
and more about your
craft through being open,
working with others, I feel
like you continue to learn.
I was sitting at Prairie
School last time here--
I've actually never tended
bar at Prairie School
yet, which, to me, is--
when I have to tend
bar, I know I've failed.
AMY STARR: What are you
doing a little later?
JIM MEEHAN: Thankfully,
you will not see me
behind the bar tonight either.
But I watched one
of our partners--
I believe it was Scott or Ed.
He was holding both
jiggers in one hand, which
is something that came
about while I was still
behind the bar, but
I never did that.
But in order to do a one
and a half ounce pour, which
is something that-- you
usually either do something
I don't really like very much.
You pour not all the way up to
the top of the two-ounce cup,
or you have to do 3/4,
3/4, it's a double pour.
He flipped his
jiggers in such a way
so it was a one-ounce
cup and a half-ounce cup.
And he poured into both
the half and one-ounce cup,
and then dumped both cups
into the mixing glass.
And I watched him do
that, and I was like,
I've been doing this since
1995, and I had never
thought of pouring a one and a
half ounce with two jigger cups
in my hand and pouring
at the same time.
It's so simple.
But it's just something
I'd never seen done before.
And I think that those moments
for me are very exciting.
And it's the reason
why I surround myself
with young smart
people, and why I'm not
so didactic about the
way things are done.
I think if you create
enough leeway for people
to do things their way as
much as they possibly can,
as the boss, or as the
overseer or operator,
or, really, as the person who's
responsible for everything that
goes wrong, you put
yourself in a position
where you can see people do
things that you never would
have thought of, because
you gave them the runway
to take off from.
AUDIENCE: So outside of
Prairie School, which
is the best bar in
Chicago, obviously,
can you give us a
rundown of Chicago?
What are your spots,
or where do you
respect, or other cocktail bars,
or even bars, how you said,
that have that nostalgic,
authentic factor?
Because I think that's
an interesting angle.
Obviously, we have
The Aviary right here.
But there's also a lot
of good local spots,
and it seems like
you're well-traveled.
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah.
I mean, when I was
younger, I went
to all the bars in
Chicago, and that's
why I don't go to all the
bars in Chicago anymore.
All the miles in my
liver have been used up.
But today was a great example.
I showed up early
for a treatment
and was sent around the corner
to a bar called The Map Room.
And I was sent there
to get a cup of coffee.
And it's a beer bar, from
what Google tells me.
And it was amazing.
Like, I walked
into this beer bar,
and it didn't smell
like a beer bar.
I sat down at the bar.
And I looked at the spirits.
And while all the
bottles in the back bar
had pour spouts on it,
which is a no-no in my mind,
all the spirits on the back
bar were really thoughtfully
chosen, great spirits.
And the bartender
working, pouring coffee
was this incredibly,
effusively polite,
probably Mexican gentleman,
who I order a coffee from.
It was a black coffee.
It was an Intelligentsia coffee.
And I sat in the room.
And it once again had
that church-like feel.
And I would say that,
with respect to Chicago,
certainly there are the
Milk Rooms and the Aviaries
and the Billy Sundays
and the Violet Hours.
There are world class bars
that are doing next level
stuff that I would put up
against the bars in San
Francisco or New
York, or London.
But I find that the
taverns that I visit--
the sort of corner
bars in Chicago--
are the ones that really
kind of blow me away.
And I would go back to not
just the Midwestern sense
of hospitality and
work ethic, but just
the idea that drinking
in Chicago is a thing.
Like, there's no guilt.
People have a hedonistic--
like, Wisconsin's even better.
But people eat and drink
here like it's not this thing
that they shouldn't be doing,
or this thing that they're
doing instead of yoga.
It's this thing that they do--
AMY STARR: After yoga.
JIM MEEHAN: Or before
yoga, or instead of yoga.
Is there yoga?
And I feel like the
cross-pollination of like great
bars and operators,
but great guests--
like, people who really
enthusiastically enjoy bars,
I feel like, is what makes
drinking in Chicago great.
There's a symbiotic
relationship between those
who come to bars and
those who work in bars.
And I would say that, in
many ways, when I opened PDT,
I realized very quickly
that my staff was
fully capable of
making what I thought
were complicated drinks.
What really became the challenge
was, in such a small bar,
how can I do everything
I can to make sure
that most of my guests
were sympathetic to what
we were trying to do there.
Because a couple of
bad people in a bar,
especially a small bar,
just ruins the vibe.
And in so many ways, I find that
it's so much easier to run bars
in Chicago, because
most of the guests
are nice, reasonable,
good, vibey people.
Go to the Map Room.
Have a cup of of black
Intelligentsia coffee.
AUDIENCE: Let me preface
this question with,
I used to live in East
Village in New York.
Love PDT.
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Didn't go
there nearly as often
as I'd like to, because
it was too hard to get in.
JIM MEEHAN: I apologize.
That's what most people
say on the internet, too.
AUDIENCE: And I got your book.
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I
definitely appreciate
all the thoughtfulness
and hard work
and production
that went into it.
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Also, looking forward
to The Aviary's cocktail book.
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah, their
Kickstarter updates
are unbelievable.
AUDIENCE: So with that said,
you mentioned Milk and Honey.
You usually don't get a
drink that's on a menu.
JIM MEEHAN: There is no menu.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you want
a, how do you feel today?
You know, bartenders choice.
So I wanted to hear
your opinion on,
which direction is
the industry going--
towards well thought out,
well-named cocktails,
or creative,
on-the-fly concoctions?
And what is your opinion
of, which way should it go?
JIM MEEHAN: Well, I think that,
going back to my "Matrix-y"
Pacific Northwest answer,
I think it's going in all
directions.
The cocktail culture
is growing at this sort
of exponential pace right now.
So it is definitely
going in all directions.
The reason why I
haven't chosen to go
in the
choose-your-own-adventure,
"how are you feeling,"
[INAUDIBLE] forked path,
"let me find you a drink" style
of service that you used to get
at Milk and Honey, and you still
get at some cocktail bars, is,
I feel like writing a menu
is actually really hard.
And coming up with the menu
and changing the menu--
We have what we call
a [INAUDIBLE] menu
at Prairie School, where
every two and a half weeks, we
actually change a
page of our menu.
We put three new drinks on, a
different black and green tea
or an oolong or white
tea, and a different food
dish, and a different
single-origin coffee.
So that changes every
two and a half weeks.
And then our full menu
changes, not in its entirety,
quarterly, sort of in an
American seasonal set.
So I would say that, for
me, my interest has always
been sort of pitched towards
writing and towards design.
And I find that the
menu is a way for me
to exercise my creativity in a
way that I am passionate about
and that I believe in.
And I think it's
empowering to the guest.
When your drink is
going to depend, really,
on the ability of the bartender
to take you on the forked path
that you want, if
the bartender isn't
great on taking you
on that forked path,
or the bartender doesn't want
to take you down all the roads
that are on that path,
you, as the guest,
may not really get to where
you really wanted to go.
So it puts a lot of
pressure on the bar staff
and on the person who trains
the bar staff when you put it
all on their hands.
And going back to
the question about,
do you want me to
ask about the drink,
not all guests want to
have that much interaction
with the bartender.
So going back to my simplistic,
multi-purpose iceberg analogy,
that menu allows you to deeply
engage and a lot of the path
we can take you on
and the way that we're
going to take you,
on your own terms,
ideally, if you speak
English and read English.
But it's going to let you become
more empowered, I believe.
Whereas that sort of
bartender-dependent,
choose-your-own-adventure style
is highly dependent on the sort
of knowledge and demeanor and
capabilities of the bartender,
and the willingness of the
guests to want to engage
in that way, which, I just
feel like not everyone does.
So that's my answer.
My answer would be, I have
a way of doing things.
And certainly, you
can tell by my answer,
I can tell you how I like it to
go, and why I like it that way.
But I have so much respect
for the omakase-style cocktail
experience done well.
It is very hard to do well.
I think we're out
of time, right?
AMY STARR: We have
time for one more?
All right.
Well, thank you, Jim, so much.
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you very much.
AMY STARR: Thank you all coming.
We appreciate your time.
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]